SPEAKER: Welcome to this
episode of "Click to Deploy,"
a series where we
show you how easy it
is to deploy solutions from
the Google Cloud Marketplace.
In this episode,
we'll be reviewing
how to set up a Redis instance
via the Cloud Marketplace.
In case you're unfamiliar, Redis
is an in-memory data structure
store used as a database,
cache, and message broker.
Let's start by searching for
Redis in the marketplace.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You'll see that we have a
few different deployment
options, from virtual
machines, container images,
to Kubernetes apps.
Each deployment may be deployed
with different operating
systems, security
patches, or server shapes.
For this demo, we'll choose the
Redis Enterprise Cloud option.
Redis Enterprise Cloud delivers
fully managed Redis enterprise
as a service.
It offers all the capabilities
of Redis Enterprise
while taking care of the
operational aspects associated
with operating Redis in the
most efficient manner on Google
Cloud Platform.
The landing page will
display information
about the pricing,
documentation, and support.
The pricing information
displays a high-level estimate
of charges.
Pricing for the solution is
based on hourly consumption
of Redis Enterprise shards.
Let's click the Subscribe
button to launch the solution.
Start by choosing
a billing account
and agreeing to the
terms below, which
are the terms about
subscription fee
billed monthly and
canceling the service.
You'll also notice
"Pricing Calculator,"
which can help you see
estimated costs based
on factors like time frame,
shard hours, and data transfer
costs.
We'll choose "Manage
on Provider."
From, here you create
a Redis subscription.
Choose Google Cloud
Platform as your vendor.
Choose a name.
For this video, we'll
choose "test-db."
Now choose a DB size.
For this video, I'll choose 1
gigabyte and 25,000 throughputs
per second.
As you can see, our database
has been created and connected
to Google Cloud.
Now let's test the database.
We'll run this Python script to
see if the database is working.
Please note, for the
purpose of this demo,
we use the external DB endpoint.
But we recommend that,
in production, customers
are using internal DB endpoints
within their VPC peering
connection for security
and performance reasons.
There you have it,
a Redis instance
at the click of a button.
If you enjoyed this video,
please subscribe and hit
the Like button below.
We encourage you to check
out the GCP Marketplace
and deploy the
solution on your own.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]